hey everyone and welcome to biology
professor today i'm going to continue my
recent video series on different types
of
uh animals and
plants that i have been studying in my
garden the focus of today is going to be
what you see behind me here and that is
the harness tiger moth so this is the
third video in this series the first two
were on
uh tersa stinks moths and um beach
blight aphid i've got a couple more
coming down the pipeline uh including
one on the tomato hornworm that turns
into a hawk moth and also a video about
american pokeweed which is growing in my
garden currently
let's go ahead and launch into talking
about these tiger moths
i'm going to show you from finding it in
its larval stage the caterpillar through
its pupil stage and into the adult moth
stage this is apantisis follorata and
all of the images and videos are by me
so this is my first
introduction to this little guy i found
this little caterpillar
you can see the caterpillars are known
as wooly bears and you can see why they
have these kind of
spiky little furs or hairs all over them
and i found this actually um on my back
porch like under a wooden
box that we were working with
several several
feet from the nearest vegetation
i did attempt to provide it with some
food but it wasn't interested in eating
i guess it was already done with that
phase of its larval activity
and it was pretty much ready to uh to
pupate
and so
i uh moved it into a terrarium basically
a plastic container with some soil at
the bottom and some cellophane
holes pump poked in it over the top
and um after you know a day or two it it
was forming into
it into a pupa so here's this pupil
stage
where it was constructing this uh cocoon
and the cocoon for the species is
constructed mostly from larval hairs
making for a rather fuzzy pupil case as
i read on wikipedia
and so this is kind of what i found it
seems smooth on one end but still quite
hairy on the other and i'm not sure if
maybe i was just examining it you know i
had to kind of pull it out from the um
from the soil where it kind of burrowed
down into it maybe it just wasn't done
constructing its cocoon yet but anyways
i pulled it out i'm going to play this
video and you can see it moving so it's
kind of wiggling back and forth in this
video
and that is
all movement from this creature you know
it's not me
moving it around so you can see it's
definitely still capable of some
movement and yeah
i i
never did actually get a picture of it
after this until it had emerged as an
adult and so i'm not sure if this is the
full cocoon or if it just hadn't quite
finished making its cocoon yet
so now let's talk about its adult stage
so this particular species is known as
the harnessed tiger moth
and what i've got here are two pictures
of the adult that we raised from a
caterpillar
so this one up here on the top is when
it was still inside it's kind of plastic
terrarium here it is being released into
the wild
this is actually a different adult so i
found this adult on our fence line i
think the same day i found the
caterpillar that eventually
metamorphosed into this individual on
the right so this is a separate
individual but of the same species i
confirmed the species using my eye
naturalist app which i absolutely love
so if you are interested in being able
to determine
what types of species you're looking at
all kinds of plants animals fungi
eye naturalist is a really great
resource to do that this particular type
of tiger moth the harnessed tiger moth
again that's apantisis follarata
common across the eastern half of the
usa
this one was we found it in arkansas
and i i love that it's still fuzzy can
you see how just like that woolly bear
caterpillar
had all those hairs on it even the adult
moth
is is kind of quite furry
um in in areas of its body i think it's
kind of difficult to see the fur here
and here
um i'm really kind of curious why we
don't see more fur on this one i'm
wondering if it's just because the
resolution of my camera was not that
great especially taking the picture
through a plastic barrier
or maybe it's just that this guy is
young you know freshly metamorphosed
maybe a few days later he had grown some
fur i really don't know so if you know i
would love for you to tell me in the
comments
and that is going to be it for today
thank you for listening to my lesson on
the harness tiger moth and let me know
what your thoughts are
and i guess with that i will say thank
you for watching biology professor and
i'll see you next time bye